Hello?
Hi, Amanda!
What's up?
Not much.
You sound very excited!
Yeah, I ran into one of my old friends on the street.
By accident?
What a pleasant surprise.
Yes! We went to the same school six years ago.
How did you keep in touch with her?
I couldn't.
She and her family moved to Canada.
Then, is she moving back to Korea?
No. She's just staying here for a few days.
She wants to see her relatives and friends.
She seems like a very special friend to you.
Yes, she's like my sister.
What makes her so special?
She's not only sweet but also thoughtful.
What else can you remember about her?
She used to play tennis.
Is she a professional tennis player?
No, but she is a professional mom of two lovely kids.
That's wonderful!